family and friends calling the Ohana
but to his fans he's known by a
different thing big gang daddy
this 21 year old Dane is a global
superstar carrying the hopes and dreams
of thousands of followers I idolize them
they're like God Smith won best place in
the world when you have a guy like Big
Daddy on your team you have instant fan
appeal but he's no ordinary sports me
ranima Kenza Big Daddy is one of a new
breed a professional computer gamer just
like sports athletes these guys all
strive to be the best Big Daddies the
new star player for top ranking team
cloud 9 and they're about to compete in
the biggest ever eSports tournament
these of those choirs that there is a
burning desire to be a world champion
there's an 18 million dollar prize pool
at stake but that's not all for this new
generation of athletes staying on top is
the toughest game there is very
cutthroat if you stop being the best
just for a little while that can mean
the end of your career
Bucharest Romania it's 10:00 p.m. that
cloud nines training camp for 12 hours
the team has been competing against a
rival team playing dota or Defense of
the Ancients
we it's a frenetic battle game that some
describe as chess on steroids for you
cloud 9 is eternal Envy bones 7 fatter
misery a newest member
Big Daddy who joins six months ago who
didn't you guy then there's added
pressure but my team are great I think
everybody is very funny everybody has a
good sense of humor oh my god each
teammate plays as one hero chosen from a
roster of over a hundred your everyone
all have unique abilities so the right
mix is crucial if they're to achieve
their goal of destroying the enemy teams
base I'm walking free are walking free
I'm looking for you quick thinking
lightning reaction times and teamwork
are the keys to victory it's so
important for defined people to play the
same strategy if five different people
want to play five different strategies
is gonna be very hard Big Daddies been
brought in to give cloud 9 a decisive
edge at the international a tournament
being held in Seattle in a few weeks
time how am i doing uh delima is not
sleeping well Johan is a very good
addition for us our individual skill is
very very high I think there's a
potential for a team to be the best I
can do it
cloud9 is one of the most popular
eSports teams and around the globe 134
million people now watch competitive
gaming online with tournament prize
winnings larger than in many traditional
sporting events and a young growing
fanbase in their world Big Daddy and his
teammates a rock stars and a puddle [ __ ]
for hairy annoying girlfriends yes
that's that's how I can feel like
sometimes I think is definitely like a
band or a sporting team I was traveling
over ten times last year I know but here
we have our manager pretending that
you're managing knowing some csgo yeah
he's he's such a bad manager team
manager Conrad Johnson has been dealing
with athletes and their egos for the
past three years I wanna talk to you
guys about the International plans that
we have so we're gonna arrive July 16th
we're all gonna have new laptops which
is pretty cool I'm working on getting
you business class a lot of people get
surprised and are really shocked by how
much money is in our field and you know
these guys are earning almost you know
quarter of a million dollars in
beginning of the year everything's going
good you guys feeling good that's going
on a lot of them have really become you
know the celebrities they didn't ask to
be a lot of these guys they just like
playing video games and they just happen
to play them at the high level in my
world people look up to me and that is a
very nice thought but I still want to be
able to make something I'm proud of
and not not turn into some Paris Hilton
who's just Paris Hilton I just known for
nothing that's not that's not what I
aspire to be at all
what's driving Big Daddy right now is
the chance to prove himself on the
biggest stage of all the International
but with just two weeks to go he's still
learning to gel with his new teammates
and it's not proving easy
it's your specific it's not my game hero
it's gonna be a better entire that's not
true
I will control my lane if I [ __ ] up I
have a method all bring it back
and these we're gonna work me them
general rocker boy Johan is a very very
talented player the only problem is just
putting everything together and having
very good team play that's our weakness
by far we're just trying to fit in it's
been a troublesome that sometimes I
think he's under pressure from from
everybody as teammates himself and you
know just been seen in general you can't
just be good and talented at the game
you have to have so many other skills to
be the best team empathy human skills
these are for me is so important for
showing how good you are
with only a week to go before they leave
for Seattle the teammates have returned
home for some rest
but Big Daddy isn't out enjoying the
sunshine I think this is a 24/7 job I
think that's kind of how it is for a lot
of the best players they don't just take
a week off I'm making lunch for your
hand buddy
playing computer he forget to eat I've
been playing computer games and game boy
ever since I was 1 years old
I get all the emotions you can get from
playing satisfaction depression anger
joy I'm kind of addicted I think when I
was younger it might have you know gone
over some things something so maybe
important such a school despite being
academically gifted Big Daddy dropped
out when he was just 17 to become one of
the industry's first full-time pro
gamers I still a lot of people who
wanted me to stay especially like my
school counselor my parents yeah that
was a ongoing struggle for a while
especially my mom she still wanted me to
have an education Big Daddies parents
divorced three years ago on his mom has
come around to see him before he leaves
for Seattle how much is the winner first
eleven yeah I was just worried oh yeah
ten million ten dollars Jesus Christ mom
I didn't know that there was the
possibility for him to make money and
now it's in it's crazies famous as I'm
very proud of your hang his family is
now so supportive of his gaming career
they've given him the living room the
rest of the family has to stay Adam I
need some kind of calm and quiet like
trying endosome restarting now by the
way so sorry if if you're gonna feel
ignored
that is little bit Rain Man in Johan
yeah I think that's why he's so good
Seattle
home of the fifth international the
biggest eSports tournaments in the world
and dota fever has hit 16 teams have
traveled from around the world to
compete for the 18 million dollar prize
pool
the games will be watched online by
millions around the globe as well as
thousands of fans in the arena that's my
first like eSports event it's really
ridiculously big people look up to
athletes because they can't do what they
do I feel the same way about these guys
they're celebrities absolutely
celebrities when I see them I just freak
out there completely celebrity
that's fine cloud9 zoner jack has flown
in to see his team perform I feel like
this year that we actually have a shot
of winning this 18 million dollar prize
pool I mean you win first every single
players a millionaire they just need to
get in there and played his unit
together and this is Seberg our next
opponent cloud nines first match is
against C deck a little-known Chinese
team who've come from nowhere were you
into the con on earth under the law it's
the first time they've qualified for a
top-level tournament we prepare for
almost a year for this if when it's kind
of generalize and we will do our best to
beat the crown I
yeah it's 9:30 on the night before their
first match I saw spawning cloud nines
final practice should be a time for
fine-tuning team tactics but they're
still grappling with more fundamental
issues what we asked you we're actually
getting worse
like like there's no plan we need to
[ __ ] an actual have a natural
instinct to play as a team we need to
have a natural instinct to group up
against a good team where you're [ __ ]
punished we got [ __ ] smash and folded
up like monkeys yeah it's good to talk
about it but I feel like you're putting
too much into it right before the match
against c-tech look at Noel he's already
worried now honestly he said one day
before dragons see that you can talk
about problems all the time but it's
also a question of morale you know we
gotta be feeling good about tomorrow
don't want to go into the day feeling
bad
the team is pretty stressed right now
you just need to keep calm if you have a
fist on every finger goes another way
you cannot punch anybody you know they
showed already in some games that they
can play pitch perfect finger grass
thing
it's the morning of cloud nines game
against unknown Chinese opponents c-deck
I'm here at the cloud nine not gonna win
the whole tournament I bet there were a
lot of internal issues it would be a
dream to see them win TI
have we got them big
I taste them as one of the best
tournament if not the best team on a
quick predictions name to 1000 set two o
clock after all fine
people are expecting so much from team I
really want to show how good we really
are
see
vs cloud 9 need to use their heroes to
kill the enemy and destroy their base
the first team to take over the map with
misery and Big Daddy largest winning the
game right now
it's a strong start for cloud 9
let's see Dec launch a counter-attack
just two more
see I can't really deal with that level
of aggression seed rampaging
inside of the man's the team strategy
begins to fall apart see
to see nine and collect and kill after
kill after kill
see
it's a heartbreaking a team like they've
been around for a long time it's been
the same group of players be clearly
wanting to trust each other teams that
fully trust each other and work together
as unit B for now I think it's very
unforgiving seeing a lot of the best
players I know walk around with so much
on their shoulders but for me I know I
can get back up whether it be in this
game or something else
you
you